excuse me I was wondering if I could do
a portrait for you just as you are right
there I'm gonna ask you a question now
ask the question how much do you think
an engagement ring should be so I said
no more than four okay she said 10.
10K is a lot I mean listen she's special
it's worth every time no the fact that
I'm making this step to commit to you
like is the meaning behind the ring I'm
not saying it'd be some cheap something
but you could get a nice ring for four
thousand dollars and it's four thousand
dollars on your on your finger well it
could be tender
[Laughter]
it could I mean it could I have to ask
hypothetically if someone was showing
you that they loved you every day with
devotion they care they ask questions
they tend to your emotional needs they
help you with labor they do all this
stuff but they just get you a reasonable
ring you think that somehow their Love
Is A Lie No but I can't but bro I can't
but if they did the opposite and they
got you a ring would you think that
their Love Is Real at that moment
because of some small little symbol like
that that's exactly like the
[__] that's like yeah but you
like like you don't you never say I love
you no you don't see whenever I take all
the trash you never see or whenever I
grab my maker cuff you know in your
coffee in the morning you don't see what
I cook for you you don't see when I take
you out you don't see when I you know
you see none of that but the
[__] that's gonna beat you he
said he comes back and he says yeah but
I love you you're gonna take him back
because he said I love you then I'm
sorry you're stupid
you know it's so [__] up as you said
all that you're talking about coffee and
things like that
and the last girl I was in love with see
you know we're having this conversation
she's like what are some things that you
liked about it and this is gonna sound
[__] up
I remember one time I was just working
and and like this girl came out of
nowhere she just brought like a
charcuterie thing it was like a drink so
come take a 15 minute break so I'm out
here eating cheeses I never heard of
with like fruits in it and I never
forgot that and she's like well it's not
a big thing I'm like they don't have to
be that's not what it is though what it
is you want to know another thing and
this might be the dumbest thing but this
is real
I have my CPAP machine and I had a
little um
I use that to sleep right and it has an
adapter um
and she's like yo can I use adapt on the
CPAP machine to no yeah go use it
so day goes by go to sleep and I'm like
I gotta go find the adapter I look it's
already been plugged back in it's been
put it back in place now again it
doesn't mean anything it means
everything what the [__] yes it really
does though [__] you mean it doesn't
mean anything
but I'm like to me when you're
thoughtful about little things what I'm
not even looking I think that's ever
[__] you mean it doesn't mean anything
okay I'm not crazy everything you go put
your your [__] is back in [__] hold on
you didn't you didn't you didn't put it
back in you cleaned it you put it back
in you stored it
[__] if you don't yeah if you don't get
the [__] right over here let me give you
a hug and smooch on your forehead God
damn if you go to you go to you you go
you go to the kitchen and you make me a
sandwich I didn't even ask yeah [__] I
was not even that hungry but God damn
I'm gonna eat it out of love it's the
little thing it really is yo [__] a ten
thousand dollar ring those things yo
I'll tell you I remember that for the
rest of my life things like that that
I'm like oh that's real
that's real you weren't trying to do
what you thought would make me happy I
never told you I don't even know I like
charcuterie anyways my girls like I I
folded your socks I put it back in their
place
You Beautiful [__]
you did what
don't kill me
you do what
I looked at her like I looked at her
like she was a Pagani BF
You Beautiful [__] 2.5 million
am I right yeah so I'm just letting you
guys know what I think of it I think of
those little things so just hearing this
I don't know I just sometimes I find it
a bit disappointing but again Everyone's
entitled to this [__] you're beautiful
[__] in this cold winter season you
need to come back inside and warm
yourself up the problem is the Heat and
the cold both damage your skin and you
do want to have Flawless skin and for
that you need to take care of it I use
th handling if you don't know what to do
and it's a bit overwhelming I understand
that I would suggest you to buy the
level one box which comes with all the
basics a daily face wash which gets rid
of all the dirt and Grime on your face
they got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and they're going to be able to give
you all the instruction in order for you
to have a good skin care for you to be
looking all Flawless yeah because that's
your money maker that's the first thing
that people see when they see you your
face that's right and you got to take
care of it if you click on the link
below you will not only save 30 off your
first box but you will also receive a
gift get it it's uncomplicated skin care
routine for men that's what I use look
at this flawless that shit's nice
compared to this morning you could do a
before and after hmm
uh what did you think about the whole
topic considering that you know you've
got to buy a ring and all that good
stuff
the ring that I bought was not expensive
the the ring that I bought was within my
Meats okay very much within my Meats it
was it was
it was what I could buy oh boring boring
all the ladies in the in the chat want
to know tell us how much was it that's
right 300
300K no of course I couldn't afford that
it was like three three to four three
stop it stop it three or four hundred
three hundred what say it dollars 300 to
400 yeah nice cute diamond rings with
black onyx on it and yeah three to four
hundred yeah that's acceptable oh yeah I
think it is three months of Internet
bills you couldn't say more than that
no I don't want to put myself outside in
the street like it was a it was what
year is this 1999 it was 2014. for
that's not even that's like nine years
ago with inflation that's like
five hundred dollars yeah yeah
you think that's acceptable yeah
absolutely a hundred percent yeah I
think it's perfectly acceptable and and
actually uh you [__] might
comment on that and I'll give up because
just you can buy her face when she saw
the ring that was all that that was
needed and actually I'm gonna tell you
more than that we were supposed to get
married we couldn't get married because
my Dad was supposed to celebrate this my
God my my dad got cancer right so we
canceled the marriage right when I I had
to break her the news and I was like
[__] I I I think I'm gonna have to I
think we're gonna have to cancel it
because it's not gonna happen because my
dad's not doing too well
and she said
you're the one I wanted to get married
not me
I got the ring I'm good and I was like
yeah [__] you're right yeah and I didn't
want to get married that much
you know I mean it was just the pressure
and [__] like that and even The Big
Wedding [__] I don't want a big round
why do you do a big wedding full why why
do you do a big wedding you do a big
wedding for other people you really do
you really do because there's
300 400 people that you really care
about no it's 300 people that you care
about that your parents care about that
your grandma care about that's her
grandma care about and her grandfather
Grandma care about it her parents care
about that's what it is but it's really
about you it's about you and you do you
do you and you got the pressure that you
got to do in your family but the ring
thing and everything and stuff that's
like it's it's it's it's it's it's a
it's a bit it's a bit much the ten
thousand
if you can't afford it
go ham if I was to propose her today it
would have been a little bit different I
would have increased the what let's stop
right there
if you can't afford it let me tell you
this most the people I know buying rings
are going into debt to get those Rings
absolutely you said if you can't afford
it and I agree but these [__] a
lot of them can't afford it that's not
about the pressure
but that's what I'm saying and that's
what I'm saying if you can't afford it
uh
that that's the thing it's like if you
if you can't afford it like if I was the
proposer
today that would have been a whole other
thing like I would have dropped a little
bit more on it because I can because the
Speed game okay that's the kind of okay
I have a girl that's very sensible and
everything and stuff and what does that
mean what does that mean when you say
sensible what I mean by that is that uh
a couple of a couple of time ago uh I
said I'll buy you a car I'll buy you a
Porsche and she said buy a [__]
house are you stupid and I'm like that's
the kind of [__] you want in
your life you understand what I'm saying
and I want to bought a house right right
so basically for you guys and for her
more important strategize think about
the future than to do like more because
the thing that happens the thing that
happened if if like she knew what my
situation was back then and if I would
have come to her with a ring of ten
thousand dollars she'd be like she
wouldn't even be comfortable wearing
that [__] right he's like what did you
do to get the money what did you do yeah
where is that from you don't have it
true I mean if you want a fourteen
thousand dollar uh fourteen thousand
thousand dollar winning robe a wedding
gown and if you can't afford it that's
you I wouldn't set an amount on a ring
of what a ring could be go within your
means you wanted to get like you wanted
me to ask your hands so much
but even that you wanted me to go on one
knee
huh huh you wanted me to be like hey I'm
gonna spend the rest of my life with you
I'm gonna go on one knee and ask you if
you wanna but that's not enough
I gotta give you 10 bands in the in the
form of an informative in the form of a
band nah B that's crazy that's it's not
enough
yo it's never enough it's like
[__] cannot win so I wouldn't
put a price on what a Rings had cost go
with your [__] means okay that's it
and if she says you present her to ring
and she says that's it take the ring cap
go back take your money run run or do
like one of my mans that her girl said
no her girl said no and he's wearing the
ring on his pink and he's like I'm
wearing my own [__]
I'm wearing my own [__] he said he said
no all right because of the side of the
Ring that's that's
a red flag to me I I think
if my girl told me like the ring thing
was really important and she explained
why in a way that was more than just
whoa right if she did why do you wanna
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa I want a wing and
she did more than that I promise you I
would take a strong consideration and
like adjust it I still wouldn't go above
my means because it's not my value
system and if her values dictate to me
that I need to spend something on
something frivolously I just wouldn't be
able to if it was really important like
it was a cultural thing and it made
sense fine you know like back in the day
when it came to marriage and all things
like the things had some Merit so for
example when they talk about things like
a dowry I understood why right and that
was something that the the the bride's
parents did they did so so that she
would be taken care of that shows their
financial investment as the families
locked together even marriage you're
like yeah it's about absolutely you're
right it's not about the two people
people there even though they make it
about themselves in a lot of ways it's
about the joining of families right when
you used to think of weddings and you
see them always portrayed you see like
the head of this family the head of this
family sitting at their tables and
meeting together and embracing because
the father's acknowledging the unions of
these families right that's why even
marriage used to be political
they used to marry our daughters to
other kingdoms why so that these people
can join alliances marriages was really
more so like a political thing and a
family thing than it was about two
individuals they cannot go to war with
them and my son [__] their daughter
that's real that's right that's really
stuff that happens so and then when I
when I look at a lot of stuff today and
even the way people talk about things
everything becomes about me or it
becomes about like like magic you know
and I think that's partially mostly
Disney's fault I think Disney is like so
people on like a princess experience
where they wear a white dress and they
want and if you want to have that you're
entitled to that I just I personally
don't find it appealing and I don't
think that's really meaningful but if
it's meaningful to you that's great this
is not my core values so if I'm meeting
a girl and she says 10K and she can't
give me a strong justification for why
it needs to be 10K I would walk away not
because I can't afford it because I'm
looking at you like why don't we take
this money and put in the savings for
our kids why don't we take this money
and to spend it into a great honeymoon
why don't we take this money to spend it
into Investments for the future like why
aren't we focusing that kind of cash
flow that is substantial on that instead
of this one little symbolic thing
I'm not saying you can't have money to
have fun you can't have money for a
little bit smaller Fearless things
but be reasonable I like video games if
I was spending 10 30k a year on video
games I hope my wife would look at me
like I'm a little crazy
I hope whether it's the Bugattis or
whatever it might be just people always
talking about material Goods when it
comes to their relationship just make me
cringe a little bit
it just makes me wince because I'm like
we've normalized this and all of you've
normalized it we actually make people
feel guilty for not engaging it oh
you're cheap
as if it's a reflection of the person's
character to be a little bit
conservative with their financial
spending
we've normalized
materialism to the point where if you
ain't got name brand shoes people make
fun of you for not having the right
brain on your feet you get what I'm
trying to say oh what are these what are
those right we do a lot of that
that's a weird thing to do
the middle of a serious feet what are
those but you know but that's really
what it is when it we're making fun of
folks all the time for these things oh
this is not right it's like bro why are
we so focused on everything superfluous